[Applause]
her Germany's Nazi demons back right
wing ideas dredging up the same spirits
which darkened its last century and are
they threatening this one in these
picture-perfect towns and villages we're
driving through the state of terenia in
what was the former East Germany were
meeting a man called Tommy Frank he's a
local councillor and his restaurant is
well known on the neo-nazi scene
good attack
Ayana and this is this is something you
sell in your shop yes of course which is
Hitler's schnitzel
no it's nothing with Hitler right
legally there isn't anything with Hitler
no there's nothing I don't know what you
are see there but there's nothing with
Hitler and this place feels to me and I
haven't even seen your clothes yet but
it feels like a shrine to the Third
Reich only that's from the World War one
and there's a couple of culture
thickness like Odeon and Torah and
humans were Valhalla from Greensburg
true Aryan aggression on the on the
pillows that's a Bren not my brain is a
other brand and nice pillows so I mean
this clearly says I love Hitler and 88
is known to be a number that represents
Hitler in the third life are you you
saying that doesn't say Hitler didn't
things off you don't think so you could
have chosen other letters yeah and her
ID yeah you could have chosen Germany it
could have been dodge land its Germany
Frank's worried about the erosion of
German identity threatened as he sees it
by merce immigration kcgunther Moscow
salmon Amandine opposite videos any
problem innovation Damian in their image
India it's not so communistic of a
question of not sooner as far my bustier
Alice when investment women hapless
complete others I was closely knocking
Texican here on hands-on did order the
underside Iman artists that supported so
in a leash padding hands low a new ball
welcome to Cedar Falls
and he's right about that the mood
especially in the East is turning a
backlash against the German Chancellor
Angela Merkel's decision in 2015 to open
the borders to more than a million
refugees will manage this she said but
many people feel that Germany isn't
managing and they share Frank's views on
immigration if little else proud of what
Nazi Germany achieved in the fingers we
can't talk in Germany about this time
because it's forbidden if I talk with
you over this time what I think then I
go in the jail so I can't talk with you
about this time so all about 33 to 45 we
didn't can talk because your views are
illegal that's it
Germany has tough laws on hate speech
for cars of its Nazi past but laws don't
change attitudes and attitudes are
hardening and with them people's
readiness to bend the rules
this is curtain in the next-door state
of Saxony unhurt last month a German man
died here after a fight with two
afghanistan seekers the police say he
had a pre-existing heart condition but
that hasn't stopped the far-right from
rallying
the Eagle of the third life the Black
Sun tattoo Aryan hope these men aren't
ashamed to show what they stand for
I'm proud to be a Nazi I'm proud to be a
patriot and proud to be German he says
this is David Coquette he's called for a
cleansing of the streets tactically
Monsieur taught and began in garden on
my since we have a nice toy Keating
torture then Seidman the from Judas
middle very soon wasn't Rico trouble
Seidman Anna Genson mezzotint Arden was
you're ticklish prostitution dungeon my
sensation when you say an eye for an eye
a tooth for a tooth album for all the
sign of its Anna this is dr. Anna Oh
wolf saga ballot maybe that's a violent
when Judas was in command mr. Venegas is
confused by Jewish our presenters are
and bbischof house and also the mood
here is aggressive especially towards us
and there's the implicit threat of
xenophobic violence even in the text on
this cross for interchangeable words
German victims foreign criminals or the
other way around
does Nick talk Dodger Tito and femme de
opfer did you just come by in the patio
might be available serve up mulatto for
broader DT prison
the neo-nazi fringe have been around for
decades but incidents like the one in
curtain and in Chemnitz a few weeks
before have stirred up their roots
Chemnitz was a watershed moment a week
of protests after a German citizen was
stabbed to death in a fight with two
asylum seekers straight away the
extreme-right rallied but thousands of
concerned citizens came out too angry at
the government's policies on migration
angry that they should feel unsafe on
their streets and angry at what they
called The Lying press for refusing to
hear their point of view left and on the
right side exams of a nature alone and I
just wanted to say in my hometown India
the populist anti-immigrant AFD or
alternative for Germany party seized the
moment they held a memorial procession
for the German victims of migrant
related crime the party's leader in
terenia bjorn hooker at the front of
that march he was strongly criticized
for the company he was keeping marching
alongside the anti-islam pegida group
with neo-nazis and skinheads further
back in last year's general election the
AFD shot into third place the first time
in decades that a far-right party has
made it into the parliament its leaders
seemed to make a habit of pushing the
boundaries of what's acceptable to say
in Germany poker has called for a
hundred and eighty degree reversal of
the way the country sees its Nazi past
he was almost expelled from the party
for it but he wasn't
we're now in Turin ia's main city of our
foot to meet up with him this is where
Martin Luther father of the Reformation
studied and was ordained plans to build
a mosque here have not gone down well
pigs heads were left at the site he
doesn't say much about how integrations
working nationalism and patriotism were
thoughts and feelings which dared not
speak their name in post-war Germany and
the decades of soul-searching which
Germans went through to try and come to
terms with their Nazi past but that
process happened far more in the form of
West Germany than it did here in the
former East which was cocooned in its
communist shell and where contact with
foreigners was few and far between
[Music]
no foreign faces at this AFD rally it's
an older crowd most people here would
have grown up under communism and hooker
is a big hit
[Applause]
[Music]
yes this danke Deutschland here is loud
slunts would invade every to become
Stalin's realities oh no sign of Lord he
matured the AFD is strongest here in the
East cities like Chemnitz Curtain an air
foot the narrative of preserving the
homeland resonates as distrust of the
poker is unapologetic about who showed
up in Chemnitz
under the AFD umbrella the combined
efforts on so quit st. are entirely mine
Kern's in each design mayor daughter
Elizabeth's heat on survey honest media
doesn't ask for been fun watching oom2
above amuse Nizam Superman and all my
life tea bagging on severe I mean I'd
often an obstacle medium voltage here we
are
[Music]
but the voting public don't boycott them
in its five years of existence the AFD
has won seats in almost every state
parliament in the land and it's very
likely it'll win seats in Bavaria and
hessin - which hold elections this month
which is why we've come to Munich
Aguila Markel's sister party the
Christian social Union looks set to lose
its absolute majority but it's not just
the AFD which stand to gain greens are
also doing well on a pro-europe
pro-immigration platform their candidate
Ludvig Hartmann calls the AFD a danger
to democracy to you mostly in victim
unsewn in Chemnitz a study demas 150
mcgee Dorothy MIT McKenna and then later
he can hire and hire - mm mercy on the
vaudeville from her consumers will the
other key focus is the new bands the
heads in an undertone hat on the Ithaca
with a mesh the songs and erratic child
lift metal one undecided for him emerged
is no gangsta for here an account today
he landed on his family and its height
in the American Civic
this is the square where Hitler's
propaganda minister Joseph Goebbels
called on Germans to attack Jewish
properties in Kljestan knocked it was
Goebbels who coined the term lugan
presser or lying press which has so
caught on amongst the AFD party faithful
and the idea of scapegoating a minority
which the AFD has done with migrants
feels like it's straight out of the
fascist playbook since cabinets that
have been in circles for Germany's
domestic intelligence agency that one is
professional shots to monitor the AFD
that the party is using democracy to
pursue undemocratic unconstitutional
goals but so far the government says the
criteria for monitoring the party as a
whole had not been there last month the
AFD walked out at the Parliament on mass
to protest accusations of extremism but
their connections with the extremist
elements seem a little close for comfort
comes even a minute midden Abdul via
Windham garbage cans for dusty laughter
you know you get to blame another bomb
or political certain to them kansai cans
I know what it is
[Music]
the AFD only came into being in 2013
originally as a Euroskeptic party but in
their five short years in existence
they've stirred up populist rage shifted
politics to the right and emboldened the
extremist fringes an insidious presence
whose reach spreads ever wider right at
the heart of German democracy
[Music]